le retour de guy bedos au théâtre il
retrouve jérôme savary pour l'adaptation
cette fois d'une pièce d'arthur miller
une pièce traité un peu comme un film
avec notamment de nombreux flashbacks
reportage dominique poncet et guy nevers
orchestré évidemment par jérôme savary
qui signent mise en scène et décors
voici la photo de famille de dérapage
une pièce d'arthur miller pour laquelle
guy bedos a décidé de remonter sur scène
dérapage c'est l'histoire d'un type qui
a doublement déraper dérapé dans sa vie
jusqu'à en être devenu bigame est
salement dérapé en voiture pour se
retrouver plâtre et jusqu'aux oreilles
si je suis où on est mort hier hospital
de cuir
je suis retrouvé un peu de personnages
parce que tu es vieil enfant mâle côté
via doha le côté paschini coûts afin
dit-il
je pensais pas que tu ferais quoi forcer
tu vois non plus je te jure
moi non plus je viens d'une telle
lâcheté pour tout ce qui bouge à malibu
je suis halluciné pas mon audace
j'ai pas pu résister
vous savez que jeter sans surprise après
un avion doit la nuit c'est très
américain est très universel à la fois
et ça relève un peu de pas moins de
woody allen et de kassav et s mais les
bruits allaient très jazz est entre
rires et larmes entre swing et blues
elle est comme ça il ya beaucoup de
musique de marcher un jour
[ __ ] de vie est ce qui me font chier
donc je ne crois pas la monogamie avant
qu'elle se donne dix ça va creuser pas
mal dans l'intimité des gens n'hésitent
pas que ces consciences faire non c'est
pas consensuelle c'est ça si peut
constituer comme on y voit beaucoup de
divorce à cause de cette pièce de même
pièce bourrée de flashbacks ce dérapage
se regarde comme un film un film dont
l'humour noir va comme un gant à guy